ou non
voyons là-haut
Vallée
Nous n'avons pas parlé
il se passe quelque chose
et
de petite fille
et pour l'obtenir
physique
Oh
ce genre d'actions
[Musique]
et moi
rien ou rien
de rien
J'espère bien
l'exposition l'après-midi
se nourrir de lui
et ce n'est même pas le thème utilisé
Oui oui
[Musique]
et ses habitants
un
et déjà
Oui
elle le vend et à un moment donné fait
conditions à cet effet
mais pour moi
et parfois
nous n'aurions plus d'alcool
pas cette distinction
on est à zéro dans trois euros et demi
il faut qu'on parle
Si nous partons
encore le combat
et dit allez viens
de notre village
maintenant nous disons avant ceux-ci sont les premiers
ville
Oui
singh
dans l'enseignement du stylisme
et s'il n'y a pas d'état
en 2
et ceci
je
si je ne l'ai pas parfois
[Musique]
Oui
existant
Oui oui oui
Ce n'est pas qu'ils savent marcher
ma passion
Comment sommes-nous
Oh
ici
et ce que j'ai dit
et si de quelque manière que ce soit
et le bâtiment
non
Alors
mais
ou
s
elle de la gare
Voilà
Oui
à plus
eux-mêmes
Oui
il a été mis derrière
quand même pas fermé
je
maintenant oui non
[Applaudissements]
Oui
c'est une vision
avec d'autres
nous penserons à la société
[Musique]
et le
Alors
l'itération vide de l'autisme
et tant de fois
à à
- les gens
aux garçons
bien
[Musique]
plus que
la voisine
Oui
nous allons voir
est une information
de ces informations
tombes ou sans accent
et nous lui disons
Oui
Ça existe
L'eau
ou dans le christianisme
ville
moi oui
J'aime
étant capitaine, vous avez trois femmes qui
je veux être
et nationale
voir
Oui
De la vidéo
sur l'enregistrement et tout
dans une rangée
Oui oui
Oui
et il y a des occasions où la fonction est gratuite
c'est l'europe radicale
facile
[Musique]
L'eau
l'afa d'un système visuel météorologique
Hier
Oh
s
Je voudrais
sans les gens exceptionnels
J'ai écrit avec le conventionnel
même si
[Musique]
après une belle gestion
pour consommer
[Musique]
intello
je
Quoi
Oui
ré
et dévouement avec dévouement
ils n'existent pas
dans le football principal et avec quels moyens
de communication
[Musique]
dans le cadre de notre nation
perez
est ok sont les dessins
Alors
nouvelle tradition que vous voulez
aux groupes
et comme
cause
r
contre
ce livre
[Applaudissements]